every day's a new day let's get after it
Chris Cuomo is getting after it in the
gym just like ten of these sort of you
know ten of the really light the CNN
anchor is officially out of quarantine
after testing positive for the corona
virus in March I tested positive scare
yes as you might imagine but better me
than you
now he's working on his recovery and
documenting the whole thing on his
instace Tory in a covering protocol so
recovery is a real thing
this isn't just like your typical
viruses and flus and stuff where you get
over it yeah that one day or so or
you're sideways maybe eat a little bland
diet and then you're back to the regular
and you work out a few times in your
back this is different I'm doing the
band thing which is literally just like
ten of these you know really like yep
that's Chris working it out with some
resistance bands they're explaining it
to me almost as like you know coming
back from like some major surgery or
something so there's no working out I
did 20 minutes this morning on the
elliptical machine like some low-level
just to get my heart rate up to like 130
or something for 20 minutes I did it I
didn't break out in the fever good Chris
also hit the pavement for a 25 minute
walk rocking that mask like a boss
finally outside walking around 25
minutes 12 out 12 back this is the
recovery phase I've been dreaming of
this in that basement every day's a new
day let's get after it he captioned the
clip quote waited weeks for this was
winded body may take weeks to come back
behind the camera Chris's wife Christina
who was also cleared to leave quarantine
by the CDC less than a week after Chris
revealed that she tested positive for
the virus to my
wife has once again proven that she is
the stronger part of the couple the
missus powered through this she's out of
quarantine eyes she dealt with it in a
fraction of the time so we are among the
Blessed Criss share at the moment he
officially came out of the basement
where he was self isolating away from
Christina and his three kids posting
this video to Instagram all right here
is the official on the basement cleared
by CDC little sway just worked out this
is what I've been dreaming of literally
for weeks he captioned the clip with a
drumroll please let's go yep let's get
after it Bella has of course taken the
video this is the dream just to be back
up here doing normal things thank you
for being so nice to me thank you for
taking care of everything you had -
thank you for taking care of me and
Bella thank you for stepping up and now
adding family videographer to do resume
she's rolling her eyes mm-hmm and even
though Chris is out of quarantine he
said that his recovery is gonna be more
than just physical it's gonna be mental
- man this put me into a depression I've
never had anything like this in my life
yeah it humbled me I know so many deal
with so much worse I've covered it
you've covered it I'm just saying for me
personally um not that strong and it
really tore me up inside out in terms of
making me reassess things about myself
and my life it scared me like what some
people when they get a heart attack
I know this is nothing like a heart
attack but for me it was ET recently
caught up with Christina and she echoed
Chris's sentiment explaining that doing
breathing exercises with a yoga
instructor was actually helping her
combat the anxiety yes you're helping
your lungs and your whole breathing but
you're also helping you your mental
health that's really important right now
people have been feeling really
debilitated by this virus mentally I
watched my husband suffer
without a bit and again I think it's
because of the long duration of his
virus is a minimum of 21 days for a lot
of people and it creates a lot of
anxiety so the breathing oxygenating the
brain is helping it's lowering the it's
helping your adrenals it's um it's it's
just helping with your general you know
well-beings Christina who has also
battled a Lyme disease created a
magazine and website the purest and is
an advocate for healthy living
having seen others suffer through
different ailments you know I realized
that it's all about our health if we
don't have our health there nothing
matters
there's no economy there's nothing that
that will survive survive this
[Music]